[music playing]
Spear fishing in Hawaii.
I'm like a fish out of water.
Thank god, I've got free
diving champ Kimi for a guide.
She makes it look so easy.
[music playing]
Damn, she's good.
Despite my fetching camouflage,
I can't hear a thing.
You were that close!
[inaudible]
That close.
Don't get frustrated.
Oh, man.
KIMI WERNER: Like really.
You were almost there.
That was a good fish, too.
How do you keep your
breath under such control?
Because you're holding
on to the seabed.
You have the spear in the other.
KIMI WERNER: And the
current is pushing you
back and forth the entire time.
GORDON RAMSAY: Yeah.
[inaudible]
KIMI WERNER: It's a lot of work.
GORDON RAMSAY: Right.
Here we go.
KIMI WERNER: That
was awesome, though.
[music playing]
Right.
Hold my breath.
Line up my sights.
This is just like shooting
fish in a barrel--
a very big
Pacific-Ocean-sized barrel.
Bingo.
[music playing]
Whoo, Whoo, Whoo, Whoo!
Awesome!
GORDON RAMSAY: A beauty.
I held onto the rock,
[inaudible] down the cord.
I just waited for him to pop up.
Oh, that was awesome.
GORDON RAMSAY: Whoo.
I don't want to come out.
I know.
Amazing.
Honestly.
What a teacher.
It makes you want
to live under water.
It's that exciting.
You don't want to come up.
I want to go back again.
This is an nenue.
GORDON RAMSAY: An nenue?
Yes.
GORDON RAMSAY: Did you grow
up eating fish like this?
KIMI WERNER: My dad
would go spear fishing
to put food on the table and
this is one of the main fish
that he fed us.
- Wow.
How cool.
Beautiful.
So you literally eat this raw?
KIMI WERNER: We always
would eat this fish raw.
This fish eats a lot of seaweed,
and so it tastes different
all on different
parts of the island
depending on what type of
seaweed is growing there.
Thank you.
Wow.
KIMI WERNER: Can you taste that?
That's delicious.
And it does taste a little
bit seaweedy, salty.
KIMI WERNER: A lot of times
we add seaweed for flavor.
GORDON RAMSAY: Yeah.
KIMI WERNER: With this fish,
it's already preseasoned--
GORDON RAMSAY: Thank you.
KIMI WERNER:
--because of its diet.
[music playing]
GORDON RAMSAY: I mean, it
was like the perfect trip
to any fishmonger you'll
ever go to your entire life.
I didn't think it would
taste that good and my god,
without any dressing,
without any chili or any soy,
and so that's got
me thinking now.
You know, do I make this
feast normally around the fish
locally or is it meats?
Right now, honestly,
I'm spoiled for choice.
[music playing]